who do you think is the greatest of all
time would you put hellmuth
no no he's definitely he seems like the
kind of person would mention he would
actually watch this so you might want to
be careful
as i said i love phil and i and i'm i'm
i have i would say this to his face i'm
not saying anything i don't
he's got he truly i mean he is one of
the greatest yeah i don't know if he's
the greatest he's certainly the greatest
at the world series of poker
and he is the greatest at
despite the game switching into a
pure game almost an entire game of math
he has managed to keep the magic alive
and this like just through sheer force
of will
making the game work for him and that is
incredible and i think it's something
that should be studied because it's an
example
yeah there might be some actual game
theoretic wisdom there there might be
something to be said about optimality
from studying him
right what do you mean by optimality
meaning uh or rather game design perhaps
meaning if what he's doing is working
maybe
poker is more complicated than we're
currently modeling it as
so like or there's an extra layer and i
don't mean to get too weird and wooey
but
or there's an extra layer of
ability to manipulate the things the way
you want them to go that we don't
understand yet do you think phil
hellmuth understands them is he just
generally hashtag positivity
he wrote a book on positivity and he's
he has
did
positivity a trolling book no i
seriously straight up
yeah hellmuth wrote a book about
positivity yes
okay not about i think and i think it's
about sort of manifesting what you want
and getting the outcomes that you want
by believing so much in yourself and in
your ability to win like eyes on the
prize
um
and i mean it's working the man's
delivered
where do you put like phil ivey and all
those kinds of people um i mean i'm too
i've been
to be honest too much out of the scene
for the last few years to really
i mean for life he's clearly got again
he's got that x factor um
he's so incredibly intimidating to play
against i've only played against him a
couple of times but when he like looks
you in the eye and you're trying to run
a bluff on him oh no one's made me sweat
harder than phil ivey just
um my my bluff got through actually
that was actually one of the most
thrilling moments i've ever had in poker
was it was in a monte carlo and a high
roller i can't remember exactly what the
hand was but um
i i you know i three bit and then like
just barreled all the way through
and he just like put his laser eyes into
me and i felt like he was
just scouring my soul
and i was just like hold it together
let's hold it together and he was like
you know your hand a little bit weaker
yeah i mean i was bluffing i i presu
which you know there's a chance i was
bluffing with the best hand but
i'm pretty sure my hand was worse um and
uh and he folded
i was truly one of my one of the deep
highlights of my qriket did you show the
cards are you full
what are you doing you should never show
in game night because especially as i
felt like i was one of the worst players
at the table in that tournament so
giving that information unless i had a
really solid plan that i was now like
advertising oh look i'm capable of
bluffing phil ivey but like why i would
i it's much more valuable
to take advantage of the impression that
they have of me which is like i'm a
scared girl playing a high roller for
the first time
keep that going you know
interesting but isn't there layers to
this like psychological warfare that the
scared girl
might be way smart and then like to to
flip the tables do you think about that
kind of stuff definitely yeah i mean not
to reveal information i mean generally
speaking you want to not reveal
information you know the goal of poker
is to be as
deceptive as possible about your own
strategies while
elucidating as much out of your opponent
about their own so
giving them free information
particularly if they're people who you
consider very good players
any information i give them is going
into their little database and being i
assume it's going to be calculated and
used well
so i have to be really confident that my
like meta gaming that i'm going to then
do or they've seen this so therefore
that i'm gonna be on the right level um
so it's better just to keep that little
secret to myself in a moment
you